sure you get some sleep  assassin I tomorrow will be a trying day  so I saw I don't think sleep will be an  option for anyone tonight  milady Buda  I request permission to join you in the  fight that is to come and he will keep  the hospital fires burning no I'm sure  someone else can handle such work I can  sneak into the very tent of generic code  I will steal his soul a general cannot  fight without this sword to him another  one don't you two capabilities laddie  but without you who will look after the  women the same person who keeps the  fires rate I don't know what of our lady  broch tuarach huh no one I trust with  our safety more than you  looks like you're going to have to stay  and like it that's understood